et c'est l'heure à présent de notre
focus nous vous emmenons aujourd'hui au
japon un pays vieillissant mais novateur
vous allez le voir il ya une quinzaine
d'années au qui une petite ville de
l'ouest du pays a une idée assez
originale
recycler les couches usagées de ces
personnes âgées pour chauffer les bains
publics de la ville et ainsi réduire sa
facture énergétique
vous allez le voir le pari s'est avéré
gagnant si bien que d'autres villes de
l'archipel ont repris l'idée
regardez ce reportage aoki de louis
belin constantin simon oeriu souks et
murata
des mètres et des mètres de couches pour
adultes dans cette grande surface c'est
le rayon phare de toutes les couleurs
pour tous les goûts
venir acheter ces produits n'est plus
une route ailleurs cela va encore plus
loin cette pharmacie ne vend tout
simplement pas de couches pour enfants
ici le client adulte est roi
vous voyez des illustrations un peu à la
façon de dessins animés
sur des paquets il ya des photos de
personnes âgées en pleine forme
je pense que ces produits renvoie une
image un peu gay joyeuse comme ça les
gens sont pas embarrassés au moment d
acheter
bienvenue à rookie petite ville paisible
de l'ouest japonais au pied du monde à
issel sur dix mille âmes capm ils ont
plus de 65 ans il y a quelques années
les couches constituait 10 % des déchets
jetés par les habitants 250 tonnes par
an dans cette maison de retraite 90 %
des résidents utilisent des couches pour
adultes mais ils sont aussi les acteurs
d'une écologie made in japan
l'institution a mis en place un tri
sélectif une petite révolution
de ce côté ce sont les sacs de couchage
et est ici c'est le reste des déchets
combustibles
dans des sacs spécialement conçu pour
étouffer les odeurs désagréables
185 kg de couches usagées sont
recueillis cet après midi au lieu d'être
brûlée à la déchetterie elles sont
transformés dans une usine aménagés
spécialement des infections séchage
découpage les confettis obtenu après une
première étape sont comprimés pour
former des granules inodore ou presque
c'est une odeur qui se rapproche un peu
du plastique
pour deviner le fondu
c'est vraiment léger
ces granules sont destinés aux bains
publics d'euros qui ils sont chauffés
depuis cet atelier
recycler les couches et moins cher que
le fuel ou le gaz utilisé
traditionnellement pour chauffer l'eau
des bains japonais surtout le procédé
est plus écologique
on installer une valve filtrante afin de
réduire la fumée au maximum à la sortie
pour l'environnement c'est une bonne
chose
sauf que
à l'intérieur de l'établissement thermal
les clients sont enthousiastes la ville
a réduit ses émissions de dioxyde de
carbone de 20% l'équivalent de 30 tonnes
de co2 par an
il n'y a pas du tout de mauvaises odeurs
c'est une eau de bonne qualité elle est
un peu salée et franchement je trouve
que ce n'est pas mal du tout
le fait de recycler les couches c'est
une très bonne chose
ça ne me gêne pas du tout
à l'origine de ce projet il y à une
quinzaine d'années le maire de la ville
pour lui l'avenir même de vaud qui est
en jeu
ce qui me préoccupe vraiment ici c'est
l'écart entre le nombre de personnes
âgées les deux jeunes qui travaillent
parce que quand un village vieilli la
production et la consommation chute
progressivement
en à peine 30 ans qui a perdu deux mille
habitants
[Musique]
alors une fois par semaine dans cette
salle municipale une quinzaine de
personnes âgées se réunit pour un cours
de fitness
qu'il n'y a pas de jeunes ici
les dimanches par exemple on ne voit pas
les enfants s'amusent edwards
c'est inquiétant je vois de plus en plus
de maisons abandonnées pour ceux qui
habitent ici depuis longtemps c'est
devenu bien triste dame en noir à 88 ans
il a su qu un site annie est la doyenne
du cours de fitness avec son mari 90 ans
elle n'a jamais cessé de cultiver du riz
et des légumes une santé de fer et une
autonomie totale
on a entre nous on en parle en rigolant
on ne connaît personne dans notre
entourage qui portent des couches mais
ça viendra
et si un jour il le faut ça me plairait
bien dans n'utiliser
de nos jours les couches sont très
pratiques et confortables
ya suco rastani on sait quelque chose
longtemps elle s'est occupée de sa mère
disparue à 108 en un dans le temps en
guise de couches on utilisait des tissus
fait d'anciens kimono
comme rookie à travers tout l'archipel
plusieurs municipalités ont commencé à
recycler les couches de leurs personnes
âgées de quoi réduire la dépendance du
japon aux énergies fossiles et rendre le
pays un peu plus vert
tout de suite les sports et on revient
bien sûr sur la qualification du sénégal
en finale de la can